Jay Leno it looks like he's out at the
Tonight Show and Jimmy Fallon is going
to replace them they're going to move
the tonight show to New York and there's
a lot of ways I think we can go with
this and three comedians talking about
comedy and talk about other comedians
can always be kind of dangerous so
without going to leno personally or what
you think of his comedy and all that
kind of stuff what do you make of his
endless game of the the tenant you know
the chairs of late-night talk show and
and the media that surrounds just the
circus of how it all eyes out well I
mean it was interesting 20 years ago
when the Letterman Leno thing went down
and you know it's all inside or
Hollywood you know they haven't one
wants to talk about it but the bottom
line is is that NBC is in a lot of
trouble they don't know what they're
doing I'm driving around La seeing
billboards of some of their new shows
and I'm like wow that's the solution a
new dating dating show Wow Oh NBC you're
doing great work yeah so you know
they're getting some press great for
them up you know but Leno's really solid
in Middle America he's got good numbers
he's still the leader you know with all
of that so I just I think NBC it's just
very sad to see this network do what
it's doing and I do and I think all of
this is just a reflection of their inner
turmoil all right well before we let you
jump in here let's look at the numbers
actually because they're actually
fascinating I think when you think about
what's going on here so leno is actually
winning the slot right now you can see
he's winning the slot he's still winning
with the young people they keep saying
well he only brings in the old people
but not that that many young people are
watching but and also it doesn't 18 to
49 seem too big of us a huge window 18
to ya one point when you weren't you
hanging out with all the coolest for you
access hey exactly
my hacking cough so all right let's go
there then so the number I mean to do
all those numbers just seemed bonkers
and what I think of Hollywood I think of
the word loyalty I think of loyalty
dedication honoring that golden watch at
the end of a long and well deserving
tenure yes you know there's these huge
and beautiful mountains on a range just
behind us over there but no one notices
you know why because they're old is why
no one wants to see old mountains
where's the new glacier right doesn't it
seem bizarre they're taking a preemptive
strike he's still winning with the young
people and they're still doing this
doesn't that just see what your contract
is up anyway yeah so you know I I'd I
like I said NBC that their their their
logical it's crazy I love Jimmy Fallon I
love what he's doing and you know what I
love j 2 j is who he is he's solid I
personally don't watch his stuff but I
don't it's just not my thing but he's
one of the nicest most generous men in
this town yeah a wonderful human being
so that but you know I think it's sad to
that you know they're gonna be moving it
to the east coast and there was this
tradition of you know a beautiful
downtown Burbank but you know Carson has
been gone a long time and things do move
on and and I don't know i mean is
anybody really i mean i saw the numbers
there but that's not a lot of people
watching late-night TV yeah its people
are on youtube people are watching
netflix people are you know watching the
daily show people are comparable numbers
with Tosh yeah yeah yeah Ashley's
probably yeah now at this point and
that's a burn and all that is on NBC we
want to talk about it but you know what
who really cares yeah when when's the
last time you watched The Tonight Show
who every now and then I'll check in
there's a guest I like or comedian I'm
friends with you know wish they'd be
more of those yeah I think we can all
agree used to be more comedians on those
show that's like the old days you know
what Johnny yeah used to make it make or
break a career Johnny you know I stayed
up i was on
and I think I was in like 11 through
tenth grade for the last night of the
Carson Tonight Show judge and I never
stayed up that late was a you know 1130
I was right like I was trying that
mother I mean I was in tenth grader
laughs great all right well good luck
Jay whatever happens we're really know
why he'll land on his feet he'll be okay
he'll be fine don't forget bonobos calm
is the official outfitter of the Ruben
report they've got great new slim fit
shirts I've never felt sharper enter
code trr 20 for twenty percent off your
first purchase